going back to casting from further away
you know you not being in LA so what are
some things you can advise others on
doing that I mean in terms of like
communication with their casting
director things like that that have
worked for you well I think the big
mistake is that people don't think they
need a casting director I've met so many
independent filmmakers who just cast the
movie themselves they go they have this
mentality that I'm gonna count I know
enough actors there's enough all I have
to do is put out a casting call and I'm
gonna get responses which is true but I
mean you need a casting director I mean
I can't I mean I know so many people who
don't want to work with one and for me
I've met so many people I would have
never met how to not had a casting
director there taken more seriously than
the director because you're having
someone fight for you you're having
another voice on the other end of that
computer or telephone line saying you
this script is great you need to come in
and read for this you need to meet this
director and that is a voice that as a
filmmaker you know that's another voice
you need and I've been able to I think
I've had access in my career to people
that I normally wouldn't have because I
have I work with the casting director
who does believe in me so much and it's
through loyalty it's because I've been
working with her for so long we know
each other well we're sympathetic to
each other's needs and more patient with
one another and I think that's why I've
been able to get these get these types
of people in these great actors in
low-budget movies you know when I'm
finished with the script she's the first
person I send it to or one of like one
at four or five and that's how that
happens that's how I can be in demand
Alton and cast in LA or be in LA or back
and forth or stuff like that so when you
do finally have the casting session what
are you doing what's what's the first
item of business I mean how are you
setting things up what do you have
available what can you advise to other
people well if you're if you work with
the casting director who's wise enough
to have pre reads she'll have pretty
reads with your nothing with you not
there you know you can be there you
don't have to be there will she'll just
see a bunch of people you know if you're
casting for someone like
in my movie I'm doing now I need
bilingual bilingual people Spanish in
English well she's going to see a bunch
of people who are bilingual anyway who
may or may not have a track record so
she'll see 30 people then I'll watch
I'll watch all that she'll tape it and
I'll watch all the tapes and then I'll
pick the ten that I want to see it's
callbacks then I'll be there for that
session so I'll see those ten pick two
or three that I like that still does
just because someone comes in and reads
for you doesn't mean they want the part
I mean they're just reading and once you
offer it they could be like oh it's not
enough money or this or that or they're
busy or you know just because a big a
great actor is reading for you doesn't
mean at the end of the day they're gonna
be in your movie and you know and people
who have a body of work who don't
audition you know that's a meetin
basically a meeting they they read the
script they think they could bring
something to the table you like their
body of work you sit down in a room you
have coffee and you talk about the story
that doesn't mean they're gonna do your
movie they could walk out of there say
'no
i don't really like that guy or you
could i could walk out of there saying
well not really right for this you know
so it's a process and you have to be
willing to go through it and i hear a
lot of people say oh I'm gonna cast my
friend or and I know or being in their
own movie I have friends and you know
people I know who want to be in their
own movie and you know I did there's a
lot of great actors out there and if
you're patient you don't need to be in
your own film
you